Tu es un
extraterrestre tu es super
puissant tu as récemment sauvé le monde
quand tes
amis qu'est-ce que tu aimes faire pour
t'amuser
Vengeance Je pensais plutôt à
la lecture ou ou au
yoga hé mon pote n'est-ce pas génial de enfin se
détendre je suis été  un enfant, non un guerrier,
je ne reste sur Terre que parce que j'ai fait un
vœu envers toi et le renard, alors je me suis installé
chez moi, non, nous ne transformons pas notre
salon en une sorte de
fosse de combat de gladiateurs, qu'est-ce que je fais ici, il
défiera son  ton plus grand
ennemi
c'est que notre
facteur ce n'est pas un lieu de bataille donc
je vais commencer ma quête viens de l'herbe la plupart des
gens pensent que je suis une blague je ne fais pas de
blagues je fais des
guerriers allons lui chercher des jointures
sans ses petits amis il est
vulnérable il est  la clé de notre ma nouvelle
création pour laquelle vous avez travaillé
Robotnik apporte-moi
des jointures
désolé cette voie est réservée tu penses que
tu peux prendre mon
pouvoir j'ai l'air d'avoir besoin de ton pouvoir de
quoi tu parles bien sûr nous
avons besoin de son pouvoir c'est la seule raison pour laquelle
nous  tu es
là, tu es à moi,
j'ai fait la
promesse de protéger cette
planète, je
suis prêt, oh, quelqu'un est sur le point de se faire
gifler, je pense qu'aujourd'hui va être une
belle
journée, aide-moi, tu vas le sauver, non,
il doit apprendre à sauver
lui-même, allez-y, laissez-vous
[Applaudissements]
regarder